>>Paul: Hey, good morning,
Matthew, can you hear me fine?
>>Matthew: Yes.
>>Narrator: It's 7:30 on
the north side of Chicago.
>>Paul: Okay, we're mostly here.
We're missing a couple of people.
>>Narrator: And for Walter Payton
High School's championship math team,
it's time for donuts--
>>Student: I prefer it with jelly.
>>Narrator: And distance learning.
>>Matthew: You can start
with an integer like two--
>>Narrator: A Q and A with a
mathematician in Switzerland.
>>Matthew: There's an
infinite number of integers,
so there are an infinite possible
number of states, and this turns
out to be how you can store an
arbitrary amount of information.
>>Paul: Matt Cook really is one of
the world experts in this field.
And so this is an opportunity
for them to interact
with somebody who's actually
doing research in the area
that we're talking about,
and that's really neat.
>>Narrator: At this science
math and world language magnet,
every subject seems to
have a global dimension.
>>Paul: Conceivably, if every city is
connected to every other city, like,
one obvious algorithm
here is void segment C, D.
>>In a single day, we could talk
about math problems from China,
which is how I introduced one
of my units in trigonometry.
Geometry problems from Japan,
computation problems from France,
I mean, the possibilities
are really endless.
>>Ellen: Payton began
with a vision that,
by putting together a great faculty
of teachers who had the desire
to nurture global leaders, we would
be able to create a curriculum
and programs to set us apart from
any other high school in the nation.
>>Student: [Speaking Chinese].
Narrator: One distinguishing factor
is Payton's requirement of four years
of foreign language study.
Offerings include Spanish,
French, Mandarin and Japanese.
>>Carol Ruth: [Speaking Japanese].
>>Language acquisition
is a profound thing,
because when you learn
another language,
you learn the way other people think.
You are really learning to keep
several points of view in mind.
It's important to have more than
one perspective, now more than ever.
>>Jeremy: My friends and my family,
they're very much happy to see me try
to learn these languages,
because they are quite difficult.
At the same time, they're quite
fun, and I'm learning so much
about foreign countries
and about foreign affairs,
just based on taking Japanese
for a couple of years.
>>Narrator: The school plays host
to a steady stream of visitors.
>>Ellen: Good morning, and welcome
to Walter Payton College Prep.
>>Narrator: Like this
delegation of 25 Chinese Mayors.
>>Ellen: You are in a wonderful,
wonderful city right now,
the City of Chicago,
the city of immigrants.
[Speaking Chinese].
>>Narrator: This group gathered
at The Confucius Institute,
a resource center at Payton,
funded through a partnership
between the Chinese government
and the city of Chicago.
>>Ellen: We're very proud to
host the Confucius Institute
and to give a global
perspective to our school.
[Speaking Chinese].
>>Robert: We really want to make
sure Chicago is at the forefront
of Chinese people's minds,
when they're thinking
about the United States.
So we teach our children,
not only the language,
but we teach them the Chinese
culture, and that's going
to create a strong foundation for the
city, so that more and more business
and cultural exchanges
can go on in the future.
>>Student: [Speaking Chinese].
>>Narrator: Chicago has the
largest Chinese language program
in the United States, with more
than 6,000 students studying
Chinese in 28 schools.
>>Wenya: [Speaking Chinese].
>>I have to make it fun and easy,
and then also at the same time,
they have to feel like they
are-- they're learning a lot.
>>[Speaking Chinese].
>>And then make them laugh, and I
try to make them laugh every day,
so that they think, oh,
it's not boring, and then,
when they like it, they'll do well.
>>Student: [Speaking Chinese].
>>Robert: We have many, many
students who are recent immigrants
from Mexico, and they all
speak Spanish at home,
and they are learning Chinese
and English at the same time,
so essentially, these kids will
go through 13 years of education,
where they're learning
English, Spanish and Chinese,
and they will come out pretty much
as the most marketable
students in the United States.
>>Teacher: Good.
Are we ready?
And..
>>Student: [Speaking French].
>>Narrator: Technology
plays a key role here,
from tools to create
rap videos in French..
>>Doctor: So it doesn't
cut through the aorta.
>>Narrator: To this health
class where students interact
with doctors performing open heart
surgery at a Southside hospital.
>>Teacher: What about Walter Payton,
do you guys have any questions?
>>Student: Doctor,
I was just curious.
How would this surgery differ
if somebody had already
had a bypass surgery?
>>Doctor: That's a good question.
Fundamentally it's the same
operation, you know, that--
>>Narrator: The same technology has
facilitated face-to-face encounters
with students in several
sister schools.
>>Student: I'd love to give you
some information about my school--
>>Ellen: We connect with an
all Islamic Intercity school
in Casa Blanca, Morocco, a school in
Osaka, Japan, we have sister schools
in Concepcion, Chile, and in China.
And a school in Durban, South Africa.
>>Student: I want you
to play me something.
[playing guitar].
>>Luis: It's amazing, I mean, to see
our students' reaction when they get
so see someone from South
Africa, from Morocco,
and even though they are so far,
and they speak another language,
they still do the same thing,
they still like going to movies,
they still like dancing, they
still sing and they're teenagers.
[Applause].
>>Narrator: Most students prefer
real world exchanges to virtual ones,
and by raising their own funds,
all students have the
opportunity to travel abroad.
>>Grace: When we were in France, all
the things said, Coiffeur, on it.
I think that's--
>>Narrator: French student, Grace
Stome, visited Strasbourg, France,
and spent a week in Morocco.
>>Grace: The second the plane touched
the ground, we knew this was going
to be way more than we could
ever expect, a great experience.
Everyone there was so
hospitable and welcoming.
We met all these dignitaries but
that was-- while that was nice,
it was even better to get to spend
time with the kids and talk to them,
and go to their classes, and go
home with them on home stays.
We wanted to speak French
with them, but they said, no,
no, let us speak English.
We want to show you how
we can speak English,
and it was just an eye opening
experience that I'll never forget.
>>Wenya: [Speaking Chinese].
>>Robert: Educators
should always be looking
at how can we open more
doors for students.
I find that when you
open those doors,
and when you expand those
horizons, you never can close them,
and that's going to change
these students' lives,
and their families' lives and
their communities lives forever.
>>Wenya: [Speaking Chinese].
Electronic flower?
No. Okay?
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.